[Music]
hello and welcome to the view from 22
I'm Ben Lazarus The Spectators special
projects editor I'm joined by Greg
carlstrom The Economist Middle East
correspondent and we're here today to
talk about the events from Israel and
Palestine this weekend we listen Greg
thanks for uh joining us on spec TV
today
um in light of what's been a very
interesting couple of days um how taken
aback were you on Saturday morning we're
using the word unprecedented and and I
really mean it this time I cannot
remember anything remotely like this
ever happening uh you know you've heard
Israelis drawing comparisons to 1973 in
the sense that this was an intelligence
failure not unlike the one that preceded
the yor war but the scenes that played
out in Israel on Saturday these images
of of Street to street fighting in in
Israeli cities and and kutas uh you know
of bodies piled up at bus stations or in
houses these are things that you ask
Israelis and they say the country hasn't
seen anything like this since 1948 since
the war of independence so really an
event without precedent in In Living
memory and I I I know it's sort of the
million dooll question at the moment but
but how on Earth did it happen I mean
have you have you had any steer from
from contacts at all on on how such a
sort of security failure would was
allowed to
happen no one has a good answer yet I
mean I think some of that is going to
have to wait for the inevitable
Commission of inquiry that looks into
this after the war ends but talking to
Israelis a couple of things come up one
of them is that the Army and the
security services they've been focused
elsewhere uh in recent months there's
been a lot of concern about the West
Bank where because of the far-right
government that's been in control of
Israel for about a year now tensions are
to boil over expansion of settlements
and various other policies so there's
been concern about the West Bank there's
also been concern about the north there
were a lot of worries that heah in
Lebanon might try to do something not
unlike this and in Gaza meanwhile the
belief was that Hamas was relatively
quiet for now that it was content to
continue ruling over that territory that
it wanted to negotiate with Israel about
things like how much money was being
allowed in or how many workers were
being allowed to cross into Israel every
day uh there was just no belief in
Israel that the group would be
contemplating an attack like this so not
just an intelligence failure but a
conceptual failure in the sense that you
might have had some intelligence but you
weren't looking for it because you had
no idea that something like this was
plausible and where do you see Iran in
all of this I mean obviously last night
we had the The Wall Street Journal story
that um appeared at first to be quite
well sourced um in saying that Iran's
hands were all over this and and
certainly aspects of of the attack seem
to be quite quite professional for the
Palestinians and you know like the hand
gliders and and and things like that um
and just a sense that it was so
multi-prong um but now I mean a lot of
us officials and Israeli officials are
saying they have no evidence that Iran's
hand was directly involved in this uh
you know the Wall Street general report
is not correct um what's your take on
that yeah I mean we've spoken today with
American officials Israeli officials
Arab officials all of whom have said
that they haven't seen any evidence of
of direct Iranian involvement in that
way so I think when we talk about Iran's
role in this there are three things that
we can talk about the first is that of
course there was some Iranian role Iran
provides money to Hamas it provides sted
toble weapons into Gaza for years uh it
provides the group with blueprints for
making drones for making Rockets some of
which we saw used against Israel on
Saturday so of course in that sense
there is an Iranian role I think there
was also a degree of coordination in
that Hamas wouldn't do something like
this something that might draw in other
groups around the region like hasah in
Lebanon it wouldn't do something like
this without alerting Iran and alerting
other militia groups in the neighborhood
so I think likely there was some degree
of coordination quite late in the game
but the idea that Iran might have
directed this organized this been the
the prime mover behind this attack we
haven't seen any evidence to support
that and again I mean the the Army
spokesman went on television this
morning and said they haven't seen any
evidence of direct Iranian involvement
so that's a very categorical statement
coming from the military
itself and could you see Iran being
dragged into this in any um direct
manner I mean that might have seemed
Unthinkable pretty Saturday but I I mean
I spoke to quite a prominent Israeli
thinker this morning uh and also another
journalist who's very well connected um
in and based in the Middle East he
seemed to think the and both of them
both men seem to think that the idea
that that Netanyahu would be toying with
striking Iran directly is not um out of
the question currently um what would
your take be on that yeah I think we all
have to have a bit of humility myself
included in how we're analyzing this
right now because this is such an
unprecedented and such a confusing
situation so I agree with you when you
say before Saturday uh it would have
been very hard to imagine
this coming to a a direct confrontation
between Iran and Israel but I think a
couple of things that I'm looking at or
looking for right now um one of them is
right now what what Israel is doing in
Gaza this aerial bombardment that
started on Saturday that happens
unfortunately every few years in Gaza
that's sort of part for the course but
if the Israeli Army decides to go ahead
with a ground defensive that's meant to
remove Hamas from Power that's the sort
of thing that could draw in other groups
groups around the region and then this
becomes a much bigger Regional war and
and all bets are off at that point I
also think that at some point whether or
not the Israelis think that there was
direct Iranian involvement in in
organizing this attack I think at some
point they will want to settle accounts
with the Iranians but I don't think
they're going to want to do that soon uh
because they have a concern about this
becoming a multi-front war I mean
they're having still a difficult time
regaining control of their own territory
and securing their own territory the
last thing they want is for this to turn
into a multif front War so whatever
response it is they might direct at Iran
I think that's something they're going
to try and push off into the longer term
and just going back to I mean you
mentioned the the possibility of a
ground
Invasion um now
Netanyahu um isn't really a wartime guy
I mean he doesn't want to have a he
doesn't want to put boots on the ground
in Gaza because the consequences of that
would be a lot of Bloodshed a lot of
loss of life obviously you know most of
the Hamas Fighters are operating below
ground in tunnels and you're you're
going into an area where the fighters
are beneath you and uh you're not going
to have civilians particularly friendly
to you either so inevitably Israel would
probably lose the same amount of
soldiers as they've just lost uh over
the last few days if they were to uh put
boots on the ground in in uh the Gaza
Strip um but AOS report this afternoon
that um Netanyahu briefed uh Jo Biden on
the phone yesterday that they were going
to shortly launch a ground Invasion and
the story seems quite well
sourced
um when do you think that might take
place if it is indeed going to take
place and how do you think that is going
to play
out I do think it will take place not
because netan wants it to take place not
because the Army wants it to take place
but I think it's inevitable at this
point I mean I remember in 2014 during
the the 50-day war in the summer of
2014 there was a push from the Israeli
right to do a ground invasion of Gaza
Nano ignored that because the Army was
worried that it was going to be a bloody
Urban Quagmire you look at what's
happened now though I mean the the
trigger for this war is so much bigger
than the trigger for the 2014 War uh the
public mood is very much in favor of a
strong response and the governing
Coalition in Israel is a a farri
coalition so I think there's going to be
unsurmountable pressure to go ahead with
a ground invasion but uh and probably
later this week I think the military
right now needs a few more days to call
up reservists to move material uh and
equipment to the border with Gaza but I
think it's something that within the
next week or so more likely than not
will go ahead but the question is just
then what's the end game I mean there's
that famous David Petraeus line from the
Iraq War where he said tell me how this
ends and and it's the same question now
you go in you go in big on the ground
you let's say you find some way to
remove Hamas from Power you decapitate
the leadership you take control of a
large part of Gaza then what the
Palestinian Authority is too weak to
come in and exert Authority uh there's
been some idle talk about Arab
peacekeeping forces coming in but
there's no Arab state that wants to do
that Israel doesn't want to reoccupy
Gaza again indefinitely so even if you
do a ground Invasion even if you do
decapitate the Hamas leadership then
what who takes charge after that and and
no one really has an answer for that how
concerned are you uh about Lebanon and
the potential for hisbah to um get
involved here um I mean there's there's
there's obviously been skirmishes today
um and it doesn't sound like that that
is hisbah officially that it might be
just sort of various militant type
groups who who are testing the waters
but there's obviously been a few
skirmishes on that border and you
mentioned before that the Israelis were
were were quite concerned about um the
Lebanese border before so how much scope
do you see that um might be the case
that uh hisbah might decide to to make a
move this
week I think it's a real concern that
they might be drawn into the War I don't
want to Discount that at all the
messaging that they had sent indirectly
to the Israelis is that if there is a
big ground defensive in Gaza that is
what would draw us into the war so
they've tried to make it clear almost
that if this war goes the way the 2014
War went they will sit on the sidelines
if it turn turns much bigger than that
then they will get involved what we've
seen so far there was some shelling
yesterday some mortar shelling from
Lebanon on an area called The shevah
Farms which is in the goal on Heights
it's a disputed area Lebanon claims it
as Lebanese Syria claims it is Syrian
the Israelis control it um and that's an
area where there has been periodic
fighting before and there's almost an
understanding that if Hezbollah attacks
that area they don't want it to escalate
into anything more than that so that I
read as a symbolic show of support for
the Palestinians but trying to stop well
short of getting involved then today
we've had reports that a few uh gunmen
from Lebanon crossed the border into
Israel were killed by the Israeli Army
Hezbollah very quickly put out a
statement after that saying this wasn't
us this was some Palestinian gunmen who
got OV excited was was essentially the
statement that they put out so again
trying to make it clear that they don't
want this to escalate
and they can't in some ways AFF this to
escalate Lebanon is ised in one of the
worst economic crises in modern history
right now uh and there's a lot of
Lebanese even people who are Hezbollah
supporters who might be cheering on the
Palestinians but don't want their own
country to get involved and so it would
be very politically risky for Hezbollah
to do that I think on balance they want
to stay out but logic doesn't always
apply in these situations and something
could happen that starts you up uh the
the escalation ladder as political
scientists call it whether you want to
escalate or not uh it ends up becoming
something bigger I mean you you
mentioned before that they um they sort
of have sent out this warning that that
if Israel was to go you know put boots
on the ground in in the Gaza Strip that
that would be the moment where they
might have to be drawn in I mean how
much of a red line is that for them I
mean would there be conditions on you
know whether Israel goes a mile into the
Gaza Strip or whether they you know just
simply enter the Gaza Strip what would
the conditions be that you think would
crossed line for his Bel
there we don't know and I'm not sure
anyone knows the answer to that I'm
going back again to to the idea of this
being so unprecedented I I don't think
even some of the leadership in in
Lebanon really has an answer for that so
I think they're going to have to weigh
on the one hand wanting to seem like
they're supporting hanas and supporting
the Palestinians on the other hand not
wanting to alienate the Lebanese
population and then there's also an
external consideration of what would the
Iranians want them to do and and you
could say that Iran might want them to
get involved because it might want to
take pressure off of Hamas in Gaza and
make this a bloody or multi-front War
for the Israelis you could also say at
the same time they might want hasah to
sit it out because if one of their
proxies in Gaza is being damaged by
degraded by an Israeli ground offensive
they don't want to risk another one of
their proxies in Lebanon so there's a
lot of factors at work here and I I
really don't have a defend of answer
Greg just turning to the uh hostages for
a second there's supposedly around um
130 uh according to estimates um Israeli
civilians and and indeed some foreign
Nationals as well who've been captured
and taken back to the Gaza Strip um
Hamas said that I think about four were
killed overnight during the Israeli air
strikes how um significant will the
hostages be uh when it comes to the sort
of is is response to uh Hamas here um
both when it comes to the possibility of
boots on the ground and also when it
comes to launching uh air
assaults I think in the first few days
of this the hostages haven't been that
much of a military consideration we
didn't know in the in in the hours and
days after this attack happened we
didn't know how many hostages there were
uh we didn't know where they had been
taken the Israeli government really
didn't have any information about this
and there are some reports that Hamas
itself might not have known how many
hostages were taken because it was
chaotic on Saturday and they're not sure
who took hostages and where they brought
them so the Israelis were focused on
just beginning the aerial response and
not really thinking about the hostages I
think that calculus will start to change
as they get a better sense of where
these people are as public pressure to
do something about the house situation
mounts and the Israeli government uh you
know is dealing with tearful families
who want to know why their sons and
daughters haven't been freed yet uh it's
going to start to mount and and I think
certainly when it comes to the question
of a ground invasion you have to weigh
on the one hand you could try to go in
and Free People in raids on the other
hand they could be killed in the
crossfire uh there is a risk at a large
ground Invasion that makes Hamas think
its grip on Powers threatened could lead
them to start executing hostages uh
these are all things that people are
thinking about in the Israeli defense
establishment and don't really have an
answer for you know they've dealt once
or twice with having one or two hostages
held but the idea that there are more
than 100 people scattered across the
Gaza Strip is something that Israeli
army officers have never had to
contemplate
before what sort of conditions do you do
you think the hostages will be um held
under I mean obviously we we've seen um
we've seen lots of women um there's lots
of evidence of of of rape certainly from
the the music festival um indeed there
was a clip of of one female hostage and
and um it looked quite quite apparent um
on the stains on her trouses that that
she had probably been assaulted um
there's obviously being there's soldiers
there's male civilians but there's also
very elderly people held hostage too um
what sort of conditions do you think
they might be held under
currently I mean the hope is that the
logic for Hamas would be that these
hostages are worth far more Al and well
treated than they are dead or abused so
you would hope that that logic would
Prevail I mean if the idea here for
hanas is that they want to exchange
these people uh in a a prisoner swap
with Israel in exchange for Palestinian
prisoners you would hope that that gives
them some incentive to treat them well
but what conditions they're being held
in uh I mean again I think it's it's
really impossible to say just
considering how unprecedented this all
is I mean one of the thing that strikes
me I mean when it sort of on Saturday it
became so apparent how many people have
been taken and I I should for um just um
U to be to be uh perfectly honest I I do
actually have a distant relative who who
Who's one of the hostages uh you know
very distant relative but an 84y old
grandmother uh great-grandmother in fact
um is is among the the people they they
they captured and took over
um you know with gillad shalid and I
think was it 2006 um after he was held
for about five years the Israelis had to
give a thousand soldiers in
exchange soldiers militants terrorists
whatever you want to call them um the
price that um Hamas would try and enact
in exchange for handing over
130 civilians um I mean is that a cost
that the is Israeli government can
Bear right it would be an astronomical
price uh there was a a senior leader of
Hamas who was interviewed a couple of
days ago who said that
uh in his view we have enough hostages
to free all of our prisoners all of the
Palestinian prisoners being held in
Israeli jails there about
5,200 Palestinian prisoners in Israeli
jails so they are looking at this as an
opportunity for the biggest prison or
release that anyone has ever secured in
Palestine to boost their own political
standing I don't see there being much
public appetite for that in Israel I
mean in the past there has been the
Shalit deal polls at the time showed
there was majority support 2/3 70 75% of
Israelis supported the Shalit deal even
though the numbers were so lopsided but
I think what makes this different for
the public is that you know people are
still they're burying their dead I don't
think they're going to be eager to make
a deal with the group that just killed
800 or more Israelis uh and I think for
the government there's going to be a
real concern about the precedent this
sets I mean if you reward what what was
the largest attack in is is's history
with a mass prisoner release you're all
but inviting someone else to try that
again so I I know there's obviously
going to be pressure from the families
and emotions are going to be running
high but I can't imagine a great number
of Israelis rushing to to make a
prisoner swap right now and I read that
um guar and and various other countries
are sort of uh looking to sort of get
involved and and advise on how um you
know some civilians or at least women in
children could be released do you put
any um Merit on on those sort of
murmurings or do you think it's all just
sort of hot
air uh hot air and and these countries
wanting to look like they have a role
and they're doing something but I think
the Israeli government right now I mean
I think the primary focus is going to be
on the military response I don't think
it's going to be on doing a prisoner
deal that's something that perhaps down
the road they'll be thinking about but
just given the the scale of the anger
and the grief in Israel after what
happened on Saturday uh I think this
government feels like it needs to
respond rather than talking about an
exchange just turning to the uh domestic
political situation within Israel
currently um what is the response to
Netanyahu um likely to be here um I mean
obviously he's been seen as a strong man
of Israel for for for decades but this
huge intelligence fa failure has
happened on his watch and um and now
there's big questions to to ask whether
they get you know whether they get put
boots on the ground whether they carry
on with air strikes how they get
hostages back etc etc what is the sort
of likely Israeli public response to
Netanyahu and his government
currently right I mean Netanyahu is a
politician who for decades has based his
public Appeal on security on the idea
that I am the most responsible Steward
of Israeli security and he's now
presided over the biggest security
failure in Israel in half a century so
it is hard to imagine this uh is
anything other than the end of his
political career he's going to try and
avoid that of course one thing he's
going to do which is what he often does
is try to shift the blame onto the heads
of the military and the security
services uh you know there's a reason if
you go through a list of former Israeli
Army Chiefs or Assad directors who
served under netan the vast majority of
them when they leave office end up being
very very sharp critics of the Prime min
because when things go well he takes
credit and things go badly someone else
is always to blame so he's going to try
and shift the blame but I don't see that
working I mean the backdrop to this is
almost a year of ongoing protest and
political turmoil over the judicial
reforms and some of the other policies
of his right-wing government uh he has
surrounded himself with some very
inexperienced ministers you know the
head of the police itar Ben gavier is a
right-wing ideologue who has no security
background than even serve in the
military um so I think all of this is
going to end up when the inevitable
early elections are called when the dust
settles uh it's it's really hard to
imagine this is not the end of his
career as prime minister and do you
think some of the distraction of the
last year um has been what fed into the
Palestinians taking this moment now to
Sunny launch this
offensive you hear that argument both
from Israelis and Palestinians yeah I
mean Israelis will say that the Prime
Minister has been distracted he hasn't
been thinking about security he's been
thinking about other things uh there
have been some questions around military
Readiness for example uh Army reservists
who have been threatening to boycott
their mandatory service because they
want to protest the judicial reforms
some of that is probably overblown in
terms of its impact because these
boycotts were not large scale and they
didn't go on for that long but yeah I
think this was also noticed on the other
side I think Palestinians noticed that
the Israeli government was raed the
security services at least from the
headlines that you could see seem like
they might be in disarray and and that
probably made this seem like a more
opportune moment the strike just turning
to the US for a second um since the
withdrawal of Afghanistan um there's
been a you could one could argue there's
been a power vacuum uh in the Middle
East um America is currently without
ambassadors in Egypt Lebanon and also in
Israel
um how significant do you think the sort
of pull back of a of America from the
region has been in in in the thinking of
of the Region's players whether Iran uh
Hamas or or
hisbah I'm not sure it's that
significant you know this is of course
the scale of this attack is
unprecedented but it's hardly the first
time that we've had a war in Gaza or
concerns about a war between Israel and
Lebanon um so I'm not sure that
America's inattention or America's
distraction really played a role here
but I do think one thing this points to
is America has had a theory about the
region for a number of years and I would
say it started under Donald Trump and
it's continued under Joe Biden this idea
that America's main goal in the Middle
East should be to focus on Israeli Arab
normalization deals things like the
abrahamic hords under Donald Trump and
then uh Biden's efforts to bring the
Saudis into the abrahamic hords and the
idea was that if you could get Israel
and Arab states working together talking
together uh that you would calm the
region that you would perhaps do
something to ease the Israeli
Palestinian conflict that was how they
approached Middle East policy that was
their Central focus and uh we saw in the
most spectacular and gruesome Fashion on
Saturday that it doesn't work that way
that these old problems of the Middle
East and the Israeli Palestinian
conflict is the oldest of them uh
they're not going to go away just
because the UAE and Bahrain and maybe
Saudi Arabia sign normalization deals
with Israel there's been a real American
inattention to those issues from many
years now and I think this should be a
reminder that that on a diplomatic level
America needs to be a bit more engaged
okay well look thank you very much for
for joining us on spectator TV uh today
Greg uh it's been really interesting
talking to you and and Incredibly
insightful so thank you very
[Music]
much